[Music]
competitive shooters are
filled with ways to peak one's opponents
and well pop their melons
from wide swings to stutter steps to
so-called quick leans
it's pretty much gotten to the point
where the age-old practice of
clapping kids around corners has been
elevated to not only a science
but an art form
oh oh my god that was dirty
all right
[Laughter]
in counter-strike for instance the
culture of peaking has given way
to well actual cults
don't believe me just run a quick search
in the steam groups tab
from the ferrari peak to the zaiwu peak
to the
erdogan peak who if you don't know is
the current
president of turkey there is no shortage
of
ridiculous tags with which these cracked
kitties can denote the speed at which
they swing
hell there's even a freaking heely peak
dead ct
that was an arm yeah crypto healy peak's
kind of lit
it's a movement you know i'm a part of
it but there is no peak
across the whole of esports that is as
feared
and fabled as the one that started this
trend the one that belongs to
ismail khan zantarez dortkardes
the turkish onliner who spent years
solidifying himself
as the sickest online-born aimbot
ever
because he's known for it because he's
always clearing everything it's like in
a millisecond
so how is it that zantara's emerged from
a struggling region
to become one of csgo's most revered
aimers
what might his ping have had to do with
it and will he ever
truly manage to translate his deific
deathmatch inspired
dominance onto land
of course
oh my look santaris can kill me like
this
[Music]
okay so before we wide swing straight
into things please do your boy a favor
and like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications
so you don't get xantares peaked by any
future episodes
of offbeat now if you've somehow never
heard of xantares
you obviously haven't been following cs
go very closely
he's made himself a household name over
the years by way of his
pornographic flicks his clean ass
haircuts
and of course his nearsightedness we are
measuring
the distance between centaurus's head
and
his monitor moses's head
a rooster so weird the barrel of a
desert eagle
none of the above or all of the above
all of you guys are wrong the answer is
moses's head because it was 17.8
centimeters but what zantarez is really
known for
are his peaks and the conditions
that shape them you see once upon a time
xentaras was a founding member of
space soldiers a largely unknown
up-and-coming turkish side
that stormed onto the scene way back in
2015.
now from the get-go it was clear that
their explosive
entry fragger was a cut above
he gets the first one that's the second
one gets the third one nasty play from
sontarez
the hesitation for masilian there
actually gets freeze filled
oh that's the a's there we go
by 2017 zantara's had really begun to
cement himself
as not only one of his region's most
explosive up-and-comers
but an onliner for the ages
whether he was dropping jaws on stream
or
tearing it up in officials it quickly
became apparent
that this kid was cracked
centaurus is a player he has really
really
really good aim you're not gonna see him
off peak at an angle or something like
that he's gonna peak the angle correctly
like every
time because he's used it you know you
think they're safe it's not safe
the opening things up and here come all
the grenades the balconies
smoked as well neo can't get down and
fast enough as on his own doesn't really
happen oh what is that
seriously got four kills gonna get the
ace that's gross the issue of course was
that thanks to how far east
turkey is situated space soldiers
struggled to scrim
and as a result consistently sharpened
their skills
against the rest of europe both because
they hailed from an
underdeveloped region and because of
every fps enthusiast's
worst nightmare ping okay so
quick lesson network latency is the time
it takes for one's computer to
communicate with a server
and when it's bad it can result in
rubber banding
desync and noticeable delays and hit
detection
and as anyone who's ever been wide swung
by a brazilian with a p90
can attest it's a huge deal in tactical
fps
i won't get into the nitty-gritty of it
all since well i don't actually know how
any of it works
but what you need to know is that low
ping is good since it means that your
inputs are being registered within the
server
shortly after actuation while high
paying on the other hand
is bad since there's basically this
chronic delay between when initiating an
action
and the moment that it registers within
the server
that network latency is what we all know
as lag
so if you do have high ping you're not
going to want to hold angles or make
slow methodical peaks no what you're
going to want to do
is play very aggressively since it'll
give
you and your opponent the illusion that
you're outpacing the server
in other words play fast pre-fire and
wide swing everything dude
we have 106 ms i'm playing from europe
now
i'm just thinking about it
well he took this [ __ ] to a whole other
level let's see if they can allow
centaurus to get the opening kill but of
course he counters antares one and two
as he cracks both of their skulls open
taking down rpk
and xms happy as well lying in wait for
zantarez is hunting him
like the hunter he is still so much
damage santaras it's a quad kill for him
suffice it to say zentaras was pretty
much cementing himself as the
raid boss of onliners while others had
merely adopted bad ping
xantares was born in it molded
by itself
by 2018 space soldiers were starting to
make a name for themselves
internationally they'd qualified for the
e-league major in boston and zantara's
stock as a world-class
wide swinger was really starting to rise
having been
shaped by his subpar playing conditions
zhantarez took to honing his mechanics
like no other
he knew that if he was going to come out
ahead against europe's best
he'd need to be incomprehensibly crispy
so he deathmatched a lot
and holy did it show
when you when you're seeing how santa is
actually playing
you can understand that he's playing a
lot of this much
because his trades his white peaks
is everything from this that much and it
was through that
constant incessant dm'ing that the now
famous
zantarez peak was born the style of
peaking i'm thinking of when i think of
the zanterrez peak is
close to the wall and you kind of over
swing the angle your opponent is holding
it really goes against most of the
fundamentals of peaking
where typically you're trying to be as
far away from the wall as possible
because that's the way geometry works
right but with the xantheras peak
usually it works extremely well in
scenarios where you already know where
your opponent
is because you overpeak their angle they
try to adjust and you already kill them
before they do
now it's one thing to audaciously [ __ ]
on sweaty scrubs with a deathmatch
inspired approach
the crazy thing about xantares is that
even the best players in the world
weren't safe from his peaks
i think that he's been helping him get
him to the level that he is right now
because of how many hours he put in
deathmatch because he's like always
satori speaks everything if you can say
like that because he's known for it
because he's always clearing everything
like in a millisecond
[Music]
now unfortunately as exciting and
explosive as
antares inhuman peaks were space
soldiers just
couldn't capitalize on them for pretty
much a whole year
their cinderella-esque journeys at tier
1 tournaments
inspired hope and hype only to end in
disappointment
so at the end of 2018 after months of
suffering
and some contract disputes xantara's
parted ways with space soldiers and did
the thing that made the most sense
go to germany join big and [ __ ] on
people
using an actual
[Music]
[Music]
needless to say this transition only
made zentares
nastier and over the course of 2019
he continued to cement himself as one of
the
godliest talents in counter-strike he's
up fights if he wins these first two
that's big one
he gets the second exception goes down
as well
zomtars now you see why they picked him
up that's a great sequence and he has
recovered in this round
i don't think he'll expect that third
player to be so far back but he is
looking in this direction
and he's got that as well he kills you
when you come up in a in a one-on-one
situation like there's
little few times you actually kill him
because how crisp his aim on it in it
it's just more you need to fool him in
different situations to get him off his
aim or off angle in that situation you
know because he's going to clear so many
different angles in la mila singing what
can big do to stop them they're going to
buy up as much as they can
as i think gobby dropped a an m4 for
xavier
so really just scraping the bottom of
the barrel there to see what they
whatever they can find
gobby's been the sacrifice so it'll be
interesting if he's going to try to pull
out the sprays
if you're doing the best he can finally
getting there okay zantarez two
headshots very fast indeed how could i
ever doubt the man
let me taking some damage very high and
exposed to a number of players
zantarez deleting everybody on a
bombsite
the question of course wasn't whether
he'd be good on land
since he was there was no doubt about
that the question
was how good you see spurts of
brilliance aside
big had this bad habit of remaining all
too
average when it mattered most even
though the consensus was that zantarez
might honestly be
the single greatest onliner that cs go
had ever seen
people were wondering whether he'd ever
be anything more
ah of course he saw the hope and he will
repeat sweeping like this is a major
santaras and with covet forcing
all counter-strike competition online in
2020
that skepticism only became more
pronounced
what it also did was send big straight
to the moon
it turns out that if you take the game's
most fragilicious fpler
slap him in a server and make it so that
that's where the trophies are
he's gonna [ __ ] on you kinda hard he
wants to get up
oh but he won't my god that's the center
that's the thing
jesus pretty much as soon as the game's
so-called online era was underway
big secured themselves a slew of
sorely needed championships it's ready
to come through khan hunter needs a
stand and he gets dropped immediately
shutting down looking to follow up and
it's all on to kenny he takes down the
first but that is
it big they take the series they take
the final
now rely on marky to come up big
out into the open and keto sends
them packing big take the victory it was
also around this time that zantarez's
signature preposterous peak really
started to explode
spawning a myriad of other equally
demonic profile tags
in obvious tribute to the turkish phenom
[Music]
memes aside it's hard to say with
certainty whether xantares will ever
become
lantaras i.e that top 5 player that he
so
clearly could be but what can be said
with
near certainty is that the silverware
he's amassed over the course of cs go's
online
blip should afford him the confidence he
needs to get there
yes
that is going back to b we've got this
cat fake coming through for breezy
leaving only santorus being with them
killing keita they know they
got rid of the b author there there's no
way that season's on that side of the
map right now so
temptation stations is in position
using his entire mag that lets him in
now on the reload double molly he can't
move anywhere but he can line them up
and knock them down double headshot make
it three santarez
doing it all zantarez is truly
a wonder of the counter-strike world and
the day that he's able to wide swing on
land the way he does online
it'll be a sight to see or you know not
see
because we'll all be dying to his elbow
and
[Applause]
i still wish i could get my shirt in
here i got this nice little cs go shirt
on
boosting to get the cookie jar shout out
to bts it's bts merch
xantares was shaped was born in it
molded by it molded by it
others had merely adopted bad ping
santaras was
born in it molded by it